Kelly and Conway  is one of the goats  of her job  what that woman did  I don't know of anybody is as good as  she is in what she did not many people  she's on the list of the best at what  she did with her job if there's no Kelly  and Conway Trump doesn't win 2016. I  agree with she's that much of a beast I  don't know if you agree with me or not  or you disagree but I think she's  amazing at what she does no I think Gene  provided president Trump candidate Trump  an invaluable service I think she was  one of the calmer cooler heads at the  White House in the early years when she  was there  um you know she's not part of the  president's re-election in 20 4 here  she's more a free agent now and an  analyst on Fox News